- What's this child doing?
Fuck off!
What?
I have to say that I'm not
madly keen on this Mike.
- [Jack] Why?
- Well because I'm not a Mike.
- But I think you're becoming a Mike.
Michael is the old you.
He was the guy that wore the suits.
He was the guy that wouldn't
eat any foreign food.
He was the guy that did sit-down
wees reading The Telegraph.
He was the guy that you used to be.
Mike rolls his shirtsleeves up.
Mike drinks beer.
Mike chills the fuck out.
Jack loves Mike.
- Can I say one thing after what you said?
Which is very sweet of you.
I have never sat down for a pee.
(Jack laughing)
Daddy's here.
You're with Daddy now.
Would you like a tickle?
Ticky ticky ticky ticky ticky tick
- Oh it's so creepy!
- He's a very nice boy Jack.
He's just a bit thick.
- I was a teacher back home in England.
I taught for four years in a school.
- Yes.
- He wasn't a teacher at all .
- I was!
- He was in a sit-com playing a teacher.
That's very different.
- I am a huge fan of gangsta rap.
Always wanted
- Gangsta rap?
- I am, I love gangsta rap.
- Rubbish. You used to be
obsessed with the Spice Girls.
Why are you looking at him lovingly?
- No I'm not lovingly.
I mean he's a sort of slightly
better looking version of you
I'm just thinking what might have been.
What about your grandparents
who you never met really?
I mean you do carry Jack's name.
- Yes.
- Not quite in the way
he would have wished.
- Deep.
- As a child you had everything.
I mean not just education
- Except love.
- Of course you had love.
Your mother loved you very much.
I have a young wife but
she's not as young as she was
and she's not quite as good
as she used to be in terms of,
well in the obvious way.
Yeah but I wouldn't mind
possibly having another wife.
And I mean if things get really bad
I may need to have one off
the wrist a couple of times,
but I mean that's not
being unfaithful is it?
- No.
Have you used my celebrity?
- Yeah I use it to have
regular shag-a-thons.
I remember I gave you a knee-trembler
against that palm tree.
Do you remember?
- I do!
- Those were the days.
When I was a small boy,
I was attacked by a clown once.
- [Jack] Attacked by a clown?
- Yes, attacked.
I was at the circus and I trod
on a clown's foot by mistake,
so I thought it was a comedy foot,
but in fact the man just had big feet.
There was a monk at my old school
who was quite interested in me.
But that's another story
for another program.
Remember that time when
you dug that huge hole
for Nora in the garden,
because she didn't want to be
overlooked by the neighbors
when she was sunbathing.
And when she got down to
the bottom of the hole,
she realized that the
sun didn't go down there.
And that you then had to fill in the hole,
and it took you nearly a week.
And you had chronic back pain
for the rest of your life.
- You're writing an autobiography.
Why?
- What do you mean why?
You don't need a why.
- [Jack] Yes I do!
- Autobiography.
- Who's going to be in a bookshop
browsing for autobiographies and go,
oh I wonder whose I should get
Obama's, David Beckham's,
oh or I could get this one,
which is a autobiography
of the former chairman
of the Putney Common Association.
- I wasn't the chairman of
the Putney Common Association.
I was the deputy chairman.
Edward Mullions was the chairman.
- [Jack] Okay sorry.
(laughing)
- Yes very funn.y
(upbeat music)
- Here we go!
Jam.
Panther.
- Jack.
♪ One two three ♪
♪ Hit it ♪
- What the fuck am I doing?
You're such a little shit aren't you?
God he's an annoying little shit.
Oh shit.
Stepped in a cowpat now.
Fuck off.
I've managed to get to 76
without ever sluicing my bottom.
And I'm not going to start now.
Oh please, I don't want
to know about your chafe.
Respect!
- No! (laughing)
- It was all that oh hi,
how was your day?
And I think,
fuck off.
You have the right to remain silent
but anything you say may be
used in evidence against you.
So in my opinion you
should shut the fuck up.
- This is police brutality!